the latest car trends are hitting the
runways just like models at a fashion
show but are the colors shapes and
materials used in automotive design
today the same ones that are appearing
on the catwalks and in clothing stores
among at the forum from Clyde you
definitely won't see the cuts of clothes
seen on the catwalk this season
reflected in a car silhouette but in the
interior design there's a big connection
to fashion design especially the design
of accessories I'm organises wire design
Italian designer Simona fontanella his
head of color and trim at Audi she's
responsible for the look of the cars
surfaces both inside and out fashionara
follows everything going on in the
fashion world she attends all the
fashion weeks in Paris Milan London and
New York but what works for people
doesn't always work for cars
it's very easy to buy the pink t-shirt
with I don't know big flowers now you
use it one two or three times maybe just
once and then throw it away the car is
is a big thing and and there is lower
but maybe that pink t-shirt will allow
us just to put a little pink tendence on
the bed for example for example gotland
green and Matador red currant colors
used for the audio for can also be found
in the fashion world Simona has created
mood boards using samples she's
collected from past seasons here we have
a new red and it's very deep is very
very elegant is slightly browned like
like we see the movement the movement is
going and as as you can see the the
inspiration is coming from different
world of design and is inspiration at
that designer comfort at the same time
is a confirmation that this is the right
direction to go it's easier to spot the
influence of fashion on a vehicle's
interior than on its exterior when it
comes to color and materials men's
fashion plays the biggest role not
because menswear is generally more
conservative but because men are often
the target group there is a lot of it
mainly in the main man fashion
combination of warm and cold now so you
have to as you see here they saturate
very much the colors and then combine
this warm beige for example with the
cold dark gray know and we played a lot
with a very small detail in the crafting
so the piping and then the stitching in
contrast and a detail that I Love
Actually is this uh-huh but the
treatment is open poor and the view have
a sound feeling luxury cars are to the
automotive industry what could tour is
to the fashion industry and series
production models are like the
ready-to-wear collections
yet compact cars are the most reflective
of fashion trends in literally fly the
music men you'll likely find more young
buyers in the lower price segment so
much more experimentation goes on there
with gadgets different color
combinations and different materials and
more fabric is used in this price
segment which is more easily varied as
far as color and shape is concerned
female Fabio and venison fable inform
gate while Audi is presenting its latest
vision of future mobility at the
frankfurt motor show simona is busy
collecting new sources of inspiration to
be used in cars in years to come
is not enough just to have this surface
and then the reflection with the color
for example but we want something more
what I I appreciate very much at the
moment is not just this plastic 3d but
even the 2d that gives you the effect of
the moment of the movement so it's super
interesting and I think it's something
that we can use to but ultimately it's
the more long-lived trends that wind up
being reflected in car design rather
than the flashy fads after all most
people plan to drive their cars for more
than just one season